could it be that his nfl season was
great because he took time to
hallucinate
perhaps his mvp stats aren't slipping
because he spent the off-season tripping
green bay packers quarterback aaron
rodgers declared his love for the
psychedelic drug ayahuasca on the aubry
marcus podcast
and we talked so much about it
about mental health and to me
one of the core tenets of your mental
health is that self-love
and
that's what ayahuasca did for me
was
help me see how to unconditionally love
myself
and
it's only in that unconditional
self-love
that that i'm able to truly
be able to unconditionally love others
[Music]
now that sounds like someone who's done
psychedelic drugs
take it from me a guy who's done peyote
with ainsley earhart
[Laughter]
but he didn't stop there
i really feel like that experience
paved the way for me to have
the best season in my career
wow
especially that touchdown he threw to a
four-headed dragon in scuba gear
now there's been a lot of research
showing that psychedelic drugs can
benefit mental health and a lot of it
has been conducted in my basement
but this may be the first bit of
evidence showing that they can benefit
your quarterbacking
look
call me old-fashioned i think football
players should stick to steroids
cat
what are your thoughts on this we've
we've talked about this this seems like
breakthrough yeah i guess it just
doesn't seem that crazy i mean because
ayahuasca is it's not like a party drug
it's like something that you do and
people take seriously and they look to
get something out of it to benefit their
mental health and it is really is
helpful to a lot of people and it's
common in other cultures just to us it
seems kind of crazy for a lot of people
but the only downside is in fact you do
become someone who speaks that way yeah
all of a sudden it's like it's so funny
when they talk about self-love mike
baker because i discovered self-love
with playboy yeah
yeah i completely misunderstood what he
was talking about yeah he means loving
himself yeah loving himself i know yeah
because i wanted to i wanted to make
that joke before you did
yeah
no you were in the cia obviously you
guys you you know you put drugs into
people's bodies to see to get them to
tell the truth what do you make of
ayahuasca did you ever use it on
somebody to get like the facts okay well
first of all no we don't do that
so that's completely incorrect um
but uh
look i know i know some folks to cat's
point i know some folks uh who uh are uh
using yes
and
some with ptsd
legit who were in the and
and it's actually helped them
significantly right and i know some very
high performing individuals who also use
it and
and they don't end up talking like aaron
but but i understand why and i have
absolutely zero problems with it yeah i
have not myself i have i am dying to do
it it's the only thing i probably
haven't done and
and and but everybody i know and there's
been i'd say a number of people who you
guys know on this show who do it
regularly will you come to peru with me
tyrus no
look it's not it's not you it's me
and i'm pretty sure he was high in that
interview
he was high as hell talking about
self-love and um now i can
unconditionally love i'll be honest with
you most of us don't want unconditional
love let's be honest yeah i mean you
don't mind if she gives you a kiss on
the forehead and a high when you're
watching the game but last thing you
want when you're doing something else is
someone be like i'm going to give you
unconditional love and put my arms
around you i want that you can feel my
heart beating i mean like get off me
particularly particularly you want that
kind of love if you're in the locker
room yeah you don't want that kind of i
mean listen it's big for yourself
he has found his my only thing with this
my only issue is this is when everyone
we're all different we're all
individuals and whenever one of us finds
something that works there's always this
guy who has to tell everybody how it's
going to work for them like not all of
us our only fear is finding a way to
throw balls to another millionaire to
make money you know what i'm saying if
you came into work like that and you
worked in a factory it's going to be a
short afternoon for you
yeah it's a good point experience the
turbines as they flow oh my hand's being
cut off oh my god
oh look at my blood that is your blood
cat like no one will be be like
take your unconditional love and your
bleeding ass hand and get out of here
all right last word do you greg does
this make sense to you who aaron rodgers
makes sense yeah uh
i mean look i like the fact that he's
talking about mental health right i
think you know it's important for
particularly men to destigmatize talking
about it i think that's a good thing i
don't have any experience i'm available
to come to peru with you next week
excellent and um excellent and i i i'm a
believer in unconditional love too do
you want do you want some no
um
yeah i'm not there yet yeah and you're
an american sportsman i mean you talk
about love in the in the locker room
it's all about patting each other on the
arse and that is true okay
it's not a pat it's a let's go yeah it's
a big oh it's a big [ __ ] yeah
yeah more of a spank right because it's
a gear you won't feel it anywhere else
that's all it is man that's all it is
nothing more okay don't dig yeah
i'm going to move on now you should
up next don't expect engagement rings if
you order boneless wings hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else